[Musique]
ce n'est pas le port du masque
obligatoire qui empêchera daniel de
jouer dans le métro pas du bien on
dirait qu'une vie qui recommence
à partir d'aujourd'hui la stm accueille
de nouveau les musiciens dans ses
couloirs ce que de mes pas je suis
heureux d'être de retour si ce
guitariste c'est ainsi que je gagne un
peu d'argent l'hiver venu pour commencer
trois stations de métro acceptons les
artistes berri uqam guy concordia et
jean talon
[Musique]
la réservation des emplacements se fera
en ligne on estime qu'il ya environ 200
musiciens qui pouvait faire des
performances dans le métro avant la
pandémie à l'heure actuelle on a des
jeunes soixantaine de musiciens qui sont
inscrits
les artistes apprécié des passeurs
gauche cotation fait de la bière plutôt
que des bons vieux chien quoi quand on
donne envie de danser et elle n'est
visiblement pas seuls
[Musique]
les gens pas aussi mauvais qu'ils sont
contents de nos voix mais lyon des
masques on n'est pas facile à voir mais
il y en a beaucoup qui font se marier en
blanc dit sekou de te revoir lui seul le
plaisir
la stm a retrouvé plus de la moitié de
sa clientèle depuis le début de la
pandémie on espère qu'elle retour du
musicien contribuera aussi à convaincre
le client d'être de retour dans notre
réseau et
marie-josée paquet comme radio canada
montréal
[Musique]